scp-682 the indestructible reptile  versus scp-241 good home cooking what  happens when you introduce the  humanity-hating lizard to a cookbook  that sends the person eating the recipes  into anaphylactic shock let's find out a  portion of 682 skin tissue was fixed to  a steel rod which was held by a d-class  and used to turn the pages of 241 the  cookbook displayed 99 new recipes  including three in an unknown language  two that were completely  incomprehensible and one that contained  a memetic kill agent the remaining  recipes all contained instructions that  made accurate preparation impossible  such as marinate for 900 trillion years  d-class personnel was tasked with  preparing these 93 recipes upon  completion each dish was served directly  to the lizard naturally it was able to  consume all 93 meals without any  difficulty for 682 this was most likely  one of the more enjoyable termination  attempts bon appetit